için ben tarımda teknolojiyi 2004
yılında kullandığımda bir sebebi amacım
vardı bütün Büyük bir sebebim vardı
aslında bu sebep hepimizi ilgilendiriyor
ama ben tarımın sorunları teknoloji ile
çözülecek Ben de bunu yapacağım
dediğimde ailem dedi ki de gelin aklına
taş gelmiş ve bu taşı çıkarmaya
çalıştılar benden sonra vazgeçtiler
dediler ki nasılsın da evlenince ya da
çocuk yapınca bundan vazgeçer ya kocası
izin vermez ve çocukları ile uğraşırken
o buna vakit kalmaz bir şekilde bu taş
kendiliğinden düşer ama budur Bu taşı
aklından hiç gitmedi ve ben üzerinde çok
çalıştım 15 yıl e çalışmaların sonucunda
biraz da hava atmak amacıyla
Bu da Dostlar dünyanın en iyi sosyal
girişimcisi seçildi mpbil getirecek
Madem birçok kişiden de tebrik aldım
Peki nedir bu hepinize ilgilendiren konu
küresel ısınmadan gireceğim ki çok
bilmem de her zaman da gündemdeydi
Aslında bundan sonra daha da gündemde
olacak çünkü biz artık çok çok derinden
hissedeceğiz sıcaklığın artışını
tenimizde hissedeceğiz mutluluğumuz
nüfusu azalırken hissedeceğiz ve dünyada
tarım ürünlerinin azalmasıyla
hissedeceğiz kaybolan hayvanlarla
hissedeceğiz şimdi dünyada 570 milyon
Çiftçi var bu çiftçilerin yüzde 90'dan
fazlası bu ayrı çiftçisi aile çiftçisi
dediğimizde kendi kararını alan dans
abiler kendi kararını üretim kararını al
Sen kendince yetiştiren Çiftçi demek
Türkiye'de bu rakam Sadece erkekler
sayıldığında ciğer Sadece erkeklerin
sayılmasının nedeni çekase belgesini
çocuk hepsini belgesinin arazi
sahiplerine ya da işte kiralayan
verilmesiyle yüzde 90 Onlar gerçek
sayıldığında 2100000 e tekabül ediyor ki
Ben 15 yıl önce başladığında 3200000 de
ve giderek hızla azalmakta dünyanın gıda
ihtiyacını bu küçük aile çiftçileri
yüzde sekseni karşılıyor Türkiye'de
yüzde 90 kadının karşılıyor gerisini
endüstriyel üretim Peki dünyanın suyunu
kim kullanıyor dünyanın suyunun Dünyada
ve Türkiye'de yüzde yetmiş kadarı
tarımda kullanılıyor tarımda nasıl
kullanılıyor canım çeşitleri Canın nasıl
isterse üreticinin Canın nasıl isterse
canı nasıl istiyor Çok su
O çok ürün alırım düşüncesiyle işliyor
dünyada da 800 milyon kişi açken
neredeyse 800 milyon kişi de o be Evet
ve giderek beşikte başka bir açlık
sağlıklı gıdaya erişememe veya sağlıklı
bir gıda da gıdayı seçememe sorunu var
bu durumda Üretim ne durumda diye
baktığınızda yüzde doksanı karşılayan
Çiftçiler iktiza yöntemlerle yenilikçi
yöntemler işemeden üretim yaparken
endüstriyel üretimde de çok fazla
teknoloji çok fazla yenilik var Onlar
kullanılıyor Ancak bu rekabet eşit
olmamasına rağmen ürünler eşit olarak
pazara sunuluyor ve dünyanın aşık
oh oh önceden kişilerde diyorlar ki
nasıl kurtuluruz biz bu dünyadan
dünyadaki kaynakları nasıl daha iyi
kullanırız Dünya nasıl daha iyi gider
değil biz Mars'a nasıl gideriz Tabii ki
Mars'taki çalışmalarda çok önemli
Geçende bir böcek bulundu Çok şey oldu
dünyada o gıcık bulursa üstüne basıp
edeceğimiz bir böcek böcek olması Tabii
ki çok önemli bu Mars filmleri dünyanın
geleceği filmlerinde teknolojik olarak
Her şey bizim bir çözümü bir kabini
bulmuşken işte hasta oluyorsun bir
kabine giriyorsun cadı seni
çıkartıyorlar ancak tarımda yine patates
üretmeyi aynı yöntemle aynı şekilde eden
asıl iklim şartı sağlar'ın ki eşim var
filminden bir kare patatese yetiştirelim
ve yaşamıma devam edelim dünyada bolluk
içindeyken bu kaynaklarımızı tüketme
bu Göz nasıl tüketiyoruz akıllı tarım
deyince şuanda teknolojinin tarıma
adaptasyonu geliyor aklımıza Ama buna
gerek kalmadan önce Yani önceden nasıldı
Bu fotoğraflarda gördüğünüz Kelaynak
kuşları tarlalardaki böcekleri yiyordu
şu anda tel örgüleri ağzında Birecik'te
korunmak için çok dikkatli bir şekilde
geçiriliyor ama çoğalmıyor Eskiden
Bunlar gelip tarlaları indiğinde böcek
yoksa henüz tarlada o zaman ki Çiftçiler
et bırakılmış sağa sola kitabı bir çeşit
ki böcekler çıkana kadar o Kuşlar orada
beslensin bakın uğur böceği uğur böceği
Neden uğur böceği biliyor musunuz
tarlaya giren yaprak bitlerine yediği
için tarlaya Uğur geçirdiği için ürünü
ver eklenti hareketlendirdi için uğur
böceği ve akıllı arıları hiç
de çok iyi biliyorsunuz buraların
dünyadaki görevlerini Arılar olmasa
yiyeceklerinizin birçoğunu yemeyeceğiz
kaybolacak ve Anılar yok oluyorlar Nasıl
yok oluyorlar olur böcekleri nasıl yok
oluyorsa Arılar bu şekilde yok oluyor
çünkü biz yiyeceğinizi öğretmek için bu
doğal mücadeleciler led'i kaybettiğimiz
için onlara iyi bakamadığımız için
akıllı olamadığımız için onları ilaç
diyoruz gidiyoruz gittiğimiz gelip
gelecek teknoloji akıllı teknoloji
derken bu değil ama dünya bunun içinde
çalışıyor aralar yok Olduğunda ne
yaparız diye Tedirgin korku için neler
gitmek istediğiniz gelecek mekanik
Arılar Tabii ki değil neler yapabiliriz
bu konuda dediğimizde benim aklıma gelen
taşla üzerime aldığım sorumlulukla kimse
bana bul bir şey de çalış demedim Ben
dedim ki bunu seçtim bu hayatımın
bu seçme zorun var Çünkü aklıma bu geldi
bence gidip bunları Çiftçilere anlatayım
Çiftçiler anlatırken de çölköy dolaşayım
işte 12000 köyün ilk başlangıcı tek
başına dolaşmak Bu sefer de benim aile
büyüklerinin dedi ki bizim kız
kahvelerden çıkmıyor yani kız
kahvelerden çıkmıyor kaybettik bu kızı
yani kız kafayı kırdı şimdi ne evlenince
Öncelikle de çocuk yapınca bu
amaçlarından vazgeçmişimdir çocuklarında
burada çok teşekkür ediyorum gittiğin
yolda yanımda oldukları için devam ettim
ama Türkiye'de kaç köy var kaç bin köy
var biliyor musunuz Nasıl çizim tek
başına dolaşacak başka başka çözümler
alın içine anlattım yaptım İlk şey Bir
web sayfası kurmak 2004 yılında yine
bana dediler ki Delinin hakkında bir taş
daha gelmiş okuma-yazma oranı düşük
yaşam
o 54 olan çiftçiye bilgisayar ve
internetin yaygın olmadığı bir yılda web
sayfası yapacakmış bak bak bak bak ne
yapacakmış Web sayfasını yaparken benim
bu sonuçtan aldım ya bu düşünceden
aldığım şey şuydu ya niye gitsinler ki
niye bilgisayar saniye internet alsınlar
içerik yok Türkiye'nin ilk tarımsal
içeriğine yaptık dünyadaki de iplerden
şu anda hala aktif Çiftçiler üzerinden
ihracat yapıyorlar ve bu köy köy
dolaşmaları sırasında gördükçe
çiftçilerin hepsinde cep telefonu var ve
o zaman Goller Cepte uçurumlar icat
edilebiliyorsa derecede gider diye
düşündük MEB ve esemesle bir
gönderebileceğini düşündük fal haklarını
hayatlarını çekirdek ve 1 milyon 600 bin
çiftçiye hava
o o o gün o Hava durumuna göre üründe ne
yapması gerektiğine ne aktaran biber
açıldı destekler açıldı sel geliyor
fırtına geliyor niye mesajlar gönderen
bir servis kurduk 1600000 de şu anda
aktif abonesi var Onun üzerinden de
domatesi satmak istiyorum diye bize
mesaj gönderiyorlar ve bugüne kadar da
44 bin Çiftçi e-finans attı bu da
gittiğimiz Rota Tabii ki tek başına
gitmedim ekip kurarak gittim akıllı
telefonlar İlk çıktığında Çiftçi bunu
kullanırmı kullanmaz mı diye sorgularken
ilk uygulama yaptık ve çiftçi şu anda
ürünün fotoğrafını çekerek hastalığını
sorabilir Yok ya da satabiliyor
üzerinden bütün bunları yaparken
dolaşırken o kadar çok dolaştık ya aynı
köye birkaç defa gittik ve orada
gördükçe bazı köyler çok iyi
ama bazı köyler o kadar da gelişmemiş
gelişimleri Araştırdık nasıl gelişti
bunlar diye onların da köyün delisi
dedikleri ilk uygulayıcılar önce
yapmışlar diğerleri ona bakarak yapmış
ondan yola çıkarak bizde Bir köyün
delisi olalım bize bakarak yapsınlar
diye bir teknoloji Köyü akıllı Köy kurma
Fikri ortaya çıktı bu sefer de bunun
ütopik uygulanamaz bir fikir oldu bunu
söylediler Ama biz şu gördüğünüz
bataklık araziyi bugün 200 kişilik
eğitim Salonu olan 300'ün üzerinde
hayvancılık seracılık bahçecilik
parlatırım Hepsini bir arada
gösterdiğimiz teknolojileri de olan bir
köyde Çiftçilere örnek oluyoruz ne
yapıyoruz sarılarda bu sıralar Çetin
görünce avuç nasıl sıra bunu yapabilir
yapamam ben diyebilecek sıra değil
onların kullandığı
bu teknoloji var Evet en güzel yer
burası inek tatil köyü gibi günlere
bacağımız var eleklerin Ayaklarında
parametreler var akıllı kapıdan girerken
hastalığı veya takımlar gelmişse mereye
girmiyor ayrılıyor çekince 1000 SMS
gidiyor orada Kaşım aparatları ve masaja
tarafları var orada taşınıyorlar masaj
oluyorlar süt verimleri artıyor Ondan
sonra çıkarken de toplumsal sisteminde
sıraya giriyorlar çok muntazam sıraya
giriyorlar için metro istasyonunda
göremezsiniz ve ne kimden hangi inek Sen
ne kadar sütlü ise olun sahip olan
çiftçiye de mesajla bilgi gidiyor bu bir
akıllı yaprak dijital yaprak bu ağacın
durumunu bacın değil bahçenin durumuna
bu çocuk bahçenin durumunu bize
ekranlarınıza bildiriyor basit
ekranlarla çiftçinin anlayabileceği
cildi dünyadaki her Tarım
her şeye göre yapılmış büyük şirketler
kullansın diye yapılmış para onlar da
var diye Haluk Çınar traktör
olabiliyorlar onlarında alım güçleri var
bakın Bu gördüğünüz ekranda gördüğünüz
sinek çiftçinin belası şeyinde Rusya'nın
geri gönderdiği İşte bundan sinek çıktı
Akdeniz Seni çıktığın yere geri
gönderdiğiniz onu tane diktiğiniz bir
panelle tuzakla kokuyla Gelip oraya
yapışıyor üzerinde bir fotoğraf makinesi
var küçük çiftçinin cebine fotoğraf
makinesiyle gönderiyor önceden Çünkü
gider bütün arazide inceleme yapardım
şimdi cebine bakıyor mu yiyecek ürün
atamam bunu biraz bunu da ilaç atmak
gerekmez gereksiz ilaçlamayı öneriyor
araları takip ediyoruz girişlerini
çıkışlarını içeride ne yaptıklarını
balım durumunu aranın durumu takip
ediyoruz ve aracı
bu açılması için çalışmalar yapmamız Bu
bir erkeğin sistemine Bu köyde dünyadaki
iç yapay akıllı sulama sisteminin demosu
var Bunu nasıl çalıştığını için bu Nasıl
kullandığını derdi bilgiler yayınlıyoruz
Bu bir yaş atık toplama sistemi ne yazık
ki Türkiye'de ve dünyada küçük çiftçiler
doğaya pek önem vermiyorlar kendi
tarzını önem veriyorlar sadece altta
gördüğünüz fotoğrafta ilaç atıksu aldığı
yere ilaç atıklarını attıkları yer var
Bu da Dere kenarları genelde leri
balıkları bıç evredeki yararlı böcekler
eve toprağa kirletiyor suyu kirletiyor
bunun için bir sistem yaptık her Köy
kurulması gerekiyor köyümüze Türkiye'den
ve dünyanın her yerinden Ziyaretçiler
geliyor Çiftçiler geliyor meraklı
ve yatırımcılar geliyor ve nasıl tarımın
daha iyi yapılabileceği Geleceği nasıl
götürebileceği işi nasıl
kolaylaştırdığını Çiftçi nasıl destek
olabileceğini görebiliyorlar bir Tabii
ki bizim orada sosyal çalışmalarımızda
oluyor çocuklar atarım sevdirmeye
çalışıyoruz geleceğin girişimci
çiftçileri olsun diye bir hayalimiz var
bir de okul kurmak canım teknolojioku
çiftçiliğin PlayStation yükseltmek gelir
sürebilir küresel hedeflerde 17 hedeften
un içi için ki bu tarım kapsamında
üzerinde çalışmalarımız var bu
yaptığımız çalışmalar başka ülkelere de
örnek oluyor dünyada Üşümüyorum Çiftçi
bu örneklerle çalışıyor özellikle Afrika
ülkelerinde de bu ne kadar bir mutlu
oldu o da hayalet harekete
bu şekilde sizde de kendi yolunuzda
hayallerinizi Bu saat etmeniz dileğiyle
Benim yolum bu kadar bum bum